I was laying in bed about to go to sleep,
and all I kept thinking about was this sweet,
comforting dessert I used to have growing up called mishrice.
Growing up, my German grandma would make this for me all the time.
Essentially, it's just a rice pudding.
I started by sweating down my rice and some butter,
took it off the heat, poured in some milk,
pinch of salt, some sugar and vanilla,
let that come to a boil, and then simmer for about 35 minutes.
In the meantime,
I made a quick raspberry compote with some frozen raspberries,
squeeze of lemon, and some sugar.
After it simmered for a few minutes,
I gradually added in my cornstarch slurry,
and once it was thick enough,
I let it simmer for a couple more minutes
before taking it off the heat.
One thing that's just an essential
is cinnamon sugar on top of mesh rice.
So I combined some cinnamon and sugar,
plated my rice, sprinkled that on top,
and then finished it off with some of my raspberry sauce.
I like eating this while it's still piping hot.
This was absolutely heavenly and exactly what I needed to go to sleep.